بجنين وطفل تحمل هيلينا عبء الحياه وحيده
اخذت الحرب شريكها الى جبهات القتال فزاد
الحمل ثقلا بهاجس التفكير وعما ستحمله
الاخبار في قابل الايام جاهده تحاول
الاتصال في كل يوم
الاتصال
تعال هنا
الان اسمعكم جيدا
ساعود الاتصال
ليس الاتصال بالامر السهل سريعا انقطع حبل
الطمانينه القصير
اشعر بالخوف عندما تطلق صافره الانذار
افكر فيه كيف يختبئ في الجبهه اصلي يوميا
وامل ان كل شيء على ما يرام
[موسيقى]
محظوظه هيلينا مقارنه باخرين هنا زوجته
وامهاته اسرى لا يعلم مصيرهم وهنا ايضا
ناجون من الاسر قصتان رصدناهما لصديقتين
اولغا التي تواجه مرض السرطان وهاجس الوقت
القصير مع اسر زوجها ومريانا التي قضت في
الاسر شهور حملها فعاشت ماساه الغياب
وانقطاع الامل
انظروا الى الازواج واشعر بالوحده خائفه
عليه اعلم انه يتعرض للتعذيب ولا ياكل
جيدا من الصعب ان تكون وحيدا في اثناء
العلاج او عندما اعرف انني قد اموت وحيده
في الشهر التاسع قيل لي لن تخرجي ستلدين
هنا شعرت بالخوف قالوا لي سياخذون طفل الى
ملجا ايتام كان خوفي هذا هو الاكبر
[موسيقى]
لم يعد دنيس موجوده
غيبت الحرب ضحكته وتركت جانا معطوفان من
الذكريات الذكريات قديمه جدا مع الامهات
والمكان بات خاليا جدا
اتكلم معه ابكي كل يوم ادخل الى الغرفه
اسلم عليه واخرج هذا الالم لا يزول يكبر
مع الوقت عليك الاعتياد
جنى واحده من كثيرات يقطفن شوك الحرب
ويذقن الم فراغ لن يملاه بعد الان وخلف
اخبار التقدم والتراجع في خطوط القتال
احلام كثيرين تايدها الحرب
يقولون انه لا احد يختار الحرب هنا في
اوكرانيا تعيش العائلات ايامها بين راصد
لاخبار المعارك ومقلب لصفحات الذكريات بين
مترقب لعوده الذاهبين هناك
او غيابهم الازلي
الجزيره كيف